battlefield ones closed alpha is
underway but limited access hasn't
stopped a few savvy players from mining
a bunch of data from the game's code
things like weapons gadgets and campaign
info reddit user Lobeck posted the
findings online for the whole internet
to see so what's this battlefield one
have in store for us based on the leak
it seems battlefield one will have 20
total chapters in its campaign there are
also several special dog tags you can
earn from playing the Alpha eating
certain missions and other Battlefield
games or attending live events as for
weapons the data dump suggests over 30
including something called behemoth
weapons and of course you can expect the
usual mines and medic bags as far as
gadgets will avoid any potential
spoilers here but you can head over to
the reddit thread to get the full
breakdown battlefield one comes to ps4
xbox one and pc on october 21st
battlefield insiders can get their hands
on the game october 18th on top of that
a public beta is coming later this
summer to keep up with all the latest
news from the battlefield keep your
sights on gamespot
you